he was coming over to the house and he
stay over the
house who was this man but nobody said
nothing I never said nothing because I
was too scared to say anything but I
enjoyed him being around you know I'm
saying late night sometimes I would come
in the room he be sitting there playing
the games tell
me thing to do I ain't
[Music]
saying wow man that's cool man you know
what I
man I like that hey look you know
what pain is beautiful look at that pain
is
beautiful because everybody can relate
to pain man everybody you can't tell me
everybody can't relate to pain
everybody that's one thing everybody got
in common is pain we all we all suffer
in one way or another man and it and
that looks so beautiful man I love that
I love that one man I love
that man I'll get you a copy man I love
it I like that I like to have that on my
shirt boogy man put pain pain is
beautiful people can relate to that
Boogyman is real man and I man I love
you man I appreciate the things you
doing and you bringing out the pain I
love that I miss that pain man I mean
you see the way I
look man that's that's that's beautiful
because I can identify with that you
can't tell me you can't identify with
that Mark that pain you can identify
with that pain I know you can I know you
can when I look at it you see that I had
to smile because I I can identify with
that man I love that man I just we we we
got to sponsor that boogeyman is real I
love you
m beautiful that was all right huh you
can have this one if you want oh yeah
you want to take it today or another day
I'll take take it another day put here
yeah I got to go to the do I got to go
see my doctors
today hey I like that
one